since we're talking about protein that
it wouldn't mention something that's
sort of clinically related prions so
what are prions prions are basically
just infectious proteins sometimes
they're called infectious protein
particles same thing what's the deal
with them
well they cause transmissible spongiform
encephalopathies or tses these things
are uncurable and they are 100% fatal so
they're pretty pretty brutal okay
some examples of transmissible
spongiform encephalopathies that are
caused by prions are crucified Jakob
disease or CJD and there's some
different versions of that that affects
humans and kuru also infects humans so
those are obviously the more important
ones medically but it's also bovine
spongiform encephalopathy or BSE
popularly known as mad cow disease which
of course infects cattle and then there
scrapey which infects seep and to deal
with prions is that they induce a change
to the secondary structure to otherwise
normal proteins by just simply
contacting those normal proteins and
they're pretty horrendous horrendous
diseases I mean I already mentioned
they're incurable 100% fatal fatal but
let's talk a little bit more about
prions
you